well here come the mariners taking the
field led by logan gilbert their big
right-hand rookie fish well in his last
timeout was against these a's he went
four innings giving up just a couple of
runs first pitch on the way and it's up
and into marquette and that hit him the
first pitch from logan gilbert hits
canna on the shoulder one pitch into it
a base runner for the a's here is matt
olson
olson skimming and crawford off balance
throw what a play the shift was on olson
hit a ground ball just to the right of
second base it took crawford right to
the bag where he gets cannon with the
force there so two outs on a couple of
pitches
swinging a drive into right field right
there is fraley and fraley makes the
catch lowry lines out and that'll end
the ending what a start for logan
gilbert we go to the bottom of the first
fourth start of the year for james
caprari last star was against the
seattle mariners he was terrific seven
shout out innings so i think it's going
to be interesting today how the
adjustments work for the mariners seeing
caprilian for the second time
swinging gonna miss outdoor breaking
ball and caprilian opens up the start
with a strikeout here is center fielder
kyle lewis batting up in the number two
spot
and that's back-to-back strikeout so he
gets kelvin and lewis swinging and after
one the a's and the mariners no score
here's catcher sean murphy swinging a
line shot up in the air making the catch
short stop jp crawford right at the cut
of the grass deep and short just timing
that leap going up there they go get it
and there's two outs here's moreland
who's pounding at 245.
moreland drives one to right center
field that's going to get down for hit
fraley's over to cut it off a big turn
by moreland but he'll stay there so two
out single that's the first hit in the
game and that'll bring up chapman who's
bounding at 208. swinging it's popped up
down the right field foul territory
france going back lot of room reaches up
and he makes the catch on the warning
track down the line and that will end
the inning nice catch as we go to the
bottom of the second the ninth walk that
fraley has received it comes with the
two on the bottom of the second and jose
gadoy is coming up there goes fraley
and it's into right center field fraley
making the turn and gadoy checks into
the base hit with two outs the mariners
have him on the corner and a chance for
nottingham to get the mariners on the
board the delivery is swung on it popped
up
right side foul territory might be
playable olson toward the dugout of the
mariners as they already makes the catch
so caprilian gets nottingham to pop out
and after two no score chad pinder will
start things off for the athletics swung
on a drill toward right center field on
the run out there is lewis he can't get
this one it short hops the wall around
first on his way to second is pinder
bobble momentarily chad's gonna make the
turn he's trying for third and he'll get
there without a throw so welcome side as
pinder drives one deep in the alley in
right center a bit of a bobble by lewis
gets him an extra 90 feet and the game's
first run is at third base with nobody
out and now tony kempelbach and he
swings and he sends one to left
back goes kelnick at the track reach up
at the wall makes the catch kisses into
the wall an easy tag and score as pinder
comes home and it's one nothing oakland
sac fly for tony kemp his fifth rbi of
the year with runners at second and
third one nothing oakland and now seth
brown stands in over his last 12. here's
the payoff
he got him swinging good heat at 96. and
that'll do it for the a's and we go to
the bottom of the third one nothing
oakland donovan wants to lead off and
it's a change-up roll to the backhand
side of pinder gloves throws the first
good stretch by olsen they get balton by
half a step nice play by chad getting
rid of it quickly and a good stretch of
course by the gold glover at the other
end and there's one out that's the
second walk allowed by caprilian and
that'll bring kyle lewis to the plate
good pitch by caprian off speed kept it
away and lewis strikes out for the
second time he's had a little trouble
with his fastball so he goes to the
slider and now runners are at first and
second as france comes to the plate
france have been swinging a hotter bat
recently the one two breaking ball
lifted towards center toward right
center with some room for kenna he's
going to step on the track he's going to
make the catch and the ending is going
to end we played three sean murphy
leading things off for the a's in the
fourth
how about that time though trying to get
after the breaking ball and sean murphy
strikes out a number of fastballs in on
his hands
set up in the middle of the play but
there's the slider and there's two outs
here's third baseman matt chapman
chapman takes and it's strike great call
got him looking strike on number three
for logan gilbert and it's a one two
three top of the fourth fitting for the
a's we go to the bottom of the fourth
and now the mariners have runners on it
first and second with nobody out here's
goudoi
olson's got it spins around out at
second to throw back to first cabrillian
covering and he gets his foot down and
that's a double play
great play by matt olsen there's no way
he's getting back to the back so as a
pitcher you know you have to get over
quickly
and he does and tough play for chad
pinder caprilian got to the bag
stretched like the first baseman and the
mariners have runners on at first and
third with two outs that'll bring up
second baseman donovan walton
high fly ball
out to right field
first in the show
donovan walton with a three-run home run
here in the bottom of the fourth inning
and the mariners have a 3-1 lead in the
ball game over the oakland a's and for
donovan his first home run in the big
leagues how about that three runs are in
run around at first base with two outs
kyle lewis coming up
this is lashed into left field and it
short hops defense countic was taken off
he's being waved in jaren koelnick
slides across in plenty of time
kyle lewis drives in another run and the
mariners have pushed four across in the
fourth inning line shot to the base of
the wall in left field
kellick was on the move he scores all
the way from first and the mariners now
lead oakland four to one so it's four to
one fifth inning chad double leading off
and a couple of five balls and he's
still at second and that'll bring up
olson who's bounced into a double play
and walk
that one is driven toward left center
field lewis on the move can't get it
over his head bounces off the wall
pinder will come in to score and the a's
get a big two out hit that knocks in a
run and it's four to two he decided to
go with it almost hit it out to left
side so here's lowry olson's the second
two away swing and i missed strike three
got him with an off speed pitch and that
will retire the side a's get the one run
but that's it rear high in innings for
logan gilbert continuing to add on to
that as he begins the six
strike three called rung them up 95 at
the kneecaps that's something else that
we've seen from him today we've seen a
pitch at the top of the zone with his
fastball he's been at the bottom of the
zone two outs in the sixth
moreland to the shifts
walton has it and the side retired in
order
a career best six innings for young
logan gilbert do you have canna on a
third olson on it first with two outs
the righty righty matchup here is shagua
to take over to try to get that final
out here in the top of the eighth inning
that's a balcous i wonder if he's going
to call that
so a buck and these will get a run it's
four to three he moved ever so slightly
but that's pat holberg the home plate
umpire they called it
it's almost like the wind blowing kite
and here's the fish to murphy on the way
and he swings and drives one to center
lewis going back toward right center
leaping he can't get it it's over is
headed off the wall the ball game is
tied murphy is going to second with a
double and it's four to four in the top
of the eighth sean murphy drills one out
to right center eluding the great try of
kyle lewis and these have come back and
they've tied it up in the eighth and now
the athletics have to go ahead run 90
feet away quickly here in the top half
of the ninth in a swing and a miss by
canada for strike three
and the a's have two down here at the
top of the ninth inning and now he's
gotta get man olson right here to get
his offense back to work and keep it a
4-4 tie
swinging is popped up shortstop jp
crawford drifting back drifting back
shallow left he's there and he makes the
catch and rafael montero walking that
tightrope gets to the other side
and the a's cannot score we're gonna go
to the 10th inning the a's will start
with matt olsen at second base and now
seth brown will be lifted and here comes
steven pascotti
into right field
fraley fight the sun and fraley makes
the catch
gets it back in quickly and olsen having
to stay anchored at second so two outs
now here's garcia
garcia hits it hard base hit left field
here comes olson digging around third he
will score and here miss garcia comes
through with a two-odd rbi hit now the
bottom of the tenth with the mariners
starting the inning with the runner at
second base
one away here at the bottom of the 10th
inning they'll bring up ty france
hard hit ground ball then it's in the
left field here cody mayfield kent's
throw is nowhere close and this game is
tied third base coach manny acted
jumping out of his shoes he was sending
mayfield all the way to test the arm of
tony kemp out there in left field hard
ground ball threading that gap on the
left side of the infield
they intentionally watch fraley get a
chance to double play
murph came into the game
vince hitting for gadoy back in the
eighth
and right field this very well could do
it biscotti long throw
mayor's win
murph comes through with a liner to
right to win the ball game six to five
in 10.
what a finish for the mariners and extra
innings